[Inaudible] sign an executive order, military porn.
What is it? Closed? And flights have been grounded.
Stranding millions of travelers who have lost all contact with the outer
extremities.
As the Dow Jones industrial average fell over 2000 points in its worst week.
Leading line.
[inaudible] indicate battle all over the world.
You want to fund me?
[inaudible] this is like the end of capitalism.
This is like the dorky just all over again. Then I wake up today in hospital,
the Waco hallucinate norm.
Okay, Jim,
what else is left?
But to abandon even the hope of truth and content ourselves instead,
which stories
can you look me in the eye until you've got this under control and it's not
going to end up in a disaster. Yes.
I don't know any numbers yet. What do you think it is
now? Call that number are not
default. Levels are huge. What does the disseminator say? 3.6 ranking,
but that's as high as the is 3.60 or terrible. Hey buddy,
what temperature you got? 98.6. Wait a minute. Is this thing broken again?
Our sources get as low as 10 as high as 50. I think the true number is much,
much higher.
It was at that moment that Mark Bob realized the whole world economy might
collapse. What are you doing?
We have to shut all the way down.
Not maybe we should put the city on full alert. We're
going to issue an alert. I don't want to bust up your place,
but you got an issue and alert.
You bring me in to tell me everything's fine and everything's not fine,
but I've been assured there is no problem. I'm telling you that. That is.
I prefer my opinion to yours. Sick. We're not getting sick.
We have far too much planned. Amity is a Summertown.
We need summer dollars. This could destroy the company.
The company cares about the company. What about us?
It's biggest shopping weekend of the year.
I think we need to consider closing schools down. Now,
if you fellowship concerned about the beaches,
you do whatever you have to to make them safe.
But those beaches will be open for this weekend. And right from the beginning,
you knew this was different because it was happening in small villages,
market towns. It's like Chernobyl. Regardless.
We have a protocol for scenarios like them isolating everybody.
I've already quarantined the boss and med staff, EMS crews, girls, neighbors.
Why am I in here? I'm protection is going to have to go into quarantine.
That's it. So a week. Nothing else I can do. Just wait.
Well, that just happens to be exactly what I'm looking for. I'm uh,
I'm outlining a new writing project and five months of pieces.
Just what I want to four weeks. I'm a raid the minibar. Sit back and watch.
My nine is in the super bowl. I'm not your wife and son.
How do you think don't take to it? They'll love it.
My wife is here. Do you think I would keep it in?
Pripyat if it wasn't safe at the time they tried to evacuate the cities.
It was already too late. The infection was everywhere.
[inaudible] help yourself.
[inaudible] things going. What's the Taurus
things could be better. Lloyd
things could be a whole lot better. It says here only eight weeks. Well,
that's not long enough for guys to go bunkers. Oh.
Five minutes is enough to put a man over down here. You spend weeks ago,
since we missed our Winslow was supposed to be here for two months.
It's been eight months. I mean, this is like some psychologic experimental talk.
You're saying funny.
And I ain't want him to be stranded here with some domino knitted. I said, ship,
we get the shuttle and just get the hell out of here. I can't take it anymore,
your honor, please much better. And I won't harm anybody.
And you got to let me come back and
put the government. What did they do?
There's no government of course is a government.
[inaudible] you want to hate about banking and reducing people to numbers.
Here's the number. Every 1% unemployment goes up. 40,000 people died.
Did you know that these are not statistics? Ladies and gentlemen,
they're fortune blood. I want you to find those into your memories.
You knew there was a shark out there.
You knew it was dangerous. People could swim. Anyway,
I got people to Dr. Cheever.
We all do my kids.
I don't think I wanted anything who wasn't destroying,
who is changing everything. He was making something new.
She's got a dad and he's his daughter. So I was wrong.
When I said this thing in life is as good as it gets. I think despite
this
problem has been assigned and you will stop at nothing
it's working.
We either have a high chance of killing one person or low chance of killing six
people. How do we make that? We,
this spring we lose summer is another 144
days. That don't happen again. If we do everything perfectly,
we had 533 days to our mission. They'll do it. If it goes,
it must be done. If you don't,
we'll die. If you're telling me that's not enough, I won't believe you,
Charles. What do you think you're doing? Dave and Frank.
Why don't we just wait here for a little while?
See what happens?
Do you think they're infected
just fine.